bonjour antonella beach youn et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct dans la matinale de rtl france
expliquez-nous pourquoi les les femmes
italiennes sont en particulier touché
par la crise sanitaire
bonjour à tout le monde les données qui
a fourni la liste tout national des
statistiques italiens m'ont dit que des
femmes seules et les principales
victimes de la crise déclenchée par la
pandémie il en sort c'est avec la crise
d'emploi est presque exclusivement
féminin une ennemie mais ajusté à
l'égard des femmes parce pénalisés parce
qu'ils perdent dans la pandémie est
longue
mon dieu ce coupé presque exclusivement
de la famille du travail et les co
leaders des filles et une situation déjà
présents les charges etc etc cible des
familles et des soins de ferme qui
emmagasine profonde dans le contexte
culturel italienne et compromet leur
inclusion dans le marché du travail
qui sont ces femmes massivement licencié
est ce qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont
plus touchés d'autres la plus forte
contraction de l'emploi féminin est
enregistré dans l'emploi à durée
déterminée les membres indépendants et
l'emploi à temps partiel et les éthers
qui ont observé
la plus forte contraction et déshérité
du service notamment à la brume la
destination et les aides ménagères leur
restauration l'hébergement dans la
restauration et l'hébergement des femmes
d'apprécier ce cas pour cent du total de
l'emploi et dans les airs ménagères les
femmes la prison de 4 8% de travail et
donc ça met en lumière une une mentalité
j'allais bien italienne qui est qu'ils
trouvent aussi c'est cette problématique
trouve aussi ses racines dans la
mentalité très patriarcales italienne
particulièrement en italie vous pensez
oui oui et alors est ce que ça va faire
évoluer les mentalités ce constat oui
vous pensez que ça va améliorer la
situation des femmes en mettant
justement en lumière ce problème je le
vois surtout c'est timide amélioration
n'est pas ne sommes pas soutenus par des
politiques de relance entre sur la
personne il ya des aides particulières
qui ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement justement pour ces femmes
l'institution a fait très peu jusqu'à
présent par conséquent elle devrait
développer des plans d'investissement
dédié à l'enfermement de la femme en
d'autres termes ils devraient se
concentrer sur les modulations
d'équilibré entre vie professionnelle et
privée par exemple dans des forçats des
services de garde des enfants la lutte
contre le travail à temps partiel
involontaire et l'acquisition de
nouvelles compétences en particulière
dans le domaine ce n est qu en est il de
l'avenir pensez vous que la situation va
pouvoir s'améliorer
oui nous doit améliorer par
l'institution doit travailler pour
améliorer la lah renforcement des femmes
dans la société italienne
merci beaucoup ont tourné là
bichonnés d'avoir répondu ce matin en
direct à nos questions sur rt france